vous allez voir le talent des
chroniqueurs il y en a quatre ici autour
de la table qui ont un salon puisque les
autres bien sûr qu'ils sont là on ne
sait plus agathe vous avez un talent
benjamin castaldi également mais kelly
et géraldine maillet agathe
on va démarrer par vous puisque on fait
comme ça dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre suisse ça de voir ça alors
attention agathe vous savez jouer du
synthé donne du piano alors le temps
qu'on branche merci à toi on sait jusqu
à brancher un branchement me mettez vous
derrière c'est bon vous savez faire quoi
alors parce que si c'est pour dire vous
savez jouer au piano donc l'art de
l'incroyable talent ouais en vrai c'est
ça dont je peux me rasseoir si vous
préférez jouer quoi alors je vais faire
une improvisation sur du jazz et je vais
vous montrer que vous aussi vous pouvez
jouer ce morceau non mais quoi il croit
qu à 19h48 la télé mais sûrement un truc
connu là c'est pas ce à quoi on sait pas
ces gens je peux improviser sur une base
de jazz
cela concerne un portemanteau ces
chauffeurs on a
m
c'est notamment dans les dix
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
bon sens à tout cela
la claque l'artiste
je conclus
[Applaudissements]
la corde et il a accordé aux cas c'est
bon moi j'ai toujours rêvé de jouer du
piano
ouais c'est ça c'est tout ce que vous
savez je veux pas vous jouiez deux
secondes non mais j'ai pas besoin de
vous dire je voulais dire c'est toujours
rêvé de jouer du piano à 4 et 5 ans même
talent non mais tu apprends rien à
[ __ ] à mister du piano gré si tu es
sympa agathe ne cite pas le nom du
conservatoire aux tapas y dix ans ce
n'est pas une super pub je me bourre
bien joué ça je connaisse à ces jours ci
sa mère a le regard de quelques jours
michel
les chalets si je crois qu'elle conçoit
ségala non même si je pense mabroc j'ai
du temps mais c'est un beau talent mais
c'était pas non plus ça je vous dire là
c'est pas le golden buzzer
je donne chaque année ça sinon je serais
parti
c'est castaldi qu'est-ce qui sait faire
castaldi les claquettes à je crois qu'il
est dur je suis ouvrir les yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
il a été très bon mais pourquoi quand tu
fais des claquettes de bouffon semaine
j'ai remarqué quelque chose c'est toute
l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là il a pu l'acquérir agit aussi le
talent préférait de benghazi s'est lâché
ah non non non c'est pas la première
fois que je te trouve on dirait pression
deuxième divorce il a pris ses cliques
et ses claques à me situer les intrigues
de fourrer casta ça va si l'on n'avait
pas on et comment niveau du sport parce
que là c'est parti vite c'est
généralement et vous sa part un plus
longtemps avec ce rythme on pourrait on
fait un truc alors à protéines rapport
qui lie puisque c'est de la danse comme
si on fait un truc de danse un truc un
petit peu plus posé ces connards moi
j'ai des visions j'ai un fluide alors
j'ai besoin de kelly parce que j'ai
remarqué que kelly était très connecté
avec moi huawei est ce qu elle peut
venir m'accompagner pour m'aider quand
vous allez vous d'accessoires regardez
les oreilles
voyez j'ai rien dans mes oreilles j'ai
pas d'oreillette personne ne parle
ok non je vous demander de choisir neuf
quartiers receive namoano car oui les
mecs c'est 19h00 à ovnis de kelis et mac
os x 19 cars neufs mais voteront pas
montré des mois ça ne verrouille le 3 2
carreaux ce dock carreau je suis pas
magicien comme que l'on doit bien
évidemment c'est juste une question de
l'adoption le 9
groland 9 le roi puis 8
le 10 et le complémentaire
hélas alors si leur ennemi du pognon
pour la réserve et les spécialistes chez
vous demandez s'il vous plaît si rim de
choisir une de ses cartes de les montrer
à kelly qui est connecté avec moi je
vais sortir je vais me retourner
d'accord vous montrer que je ne triche
absolument pas et je reviendrai et grâce
à qui des grâces 2008 je trouverais la
carte que vous avez choisi
alors posée mais moi j'avais parlé comme
ça je crois bien que les plus grands
magiciens
bah ça se voit pas ce qui lui prend sa
chance mais elle va revenir ou pas c'est
ma gueule ou quoi tête et regarder la
caméra c'est au tour de magie de merde
ouais c'est quoi ça cyril vous n'avez pu
choisir que le roi de trèfle
ah ouais bah ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça c'est un autre ibérique est à
vous lire on ne fait pas si nous on n'a
pas de parler aux moldus excuses
[Applaudissements]
alors alors alors ah non non non à l'a
fait ben alors qu'elle s'est calmé les
magiciens qui m'a donné le truc il
emmène loin derrière c'est à cause de
vous alors vous vous avez un incroyable
talent c'est quoi c'est le break dance
vous avez fait du breakdance toute votre
vie
ça fait combien d'années que vous n'avez
arrêté une quinzaine d'années mais va
écouter ces parties où vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que je vous dis pas ce que
j'ai fait est là c'est pour ça que vous
voyez vous entraîner à faire des toupies
comment fait elle quel pays ça j'ai
débuté je m'avoue d'où je vous fais
jours sur 7 quand même d'accord mais bon
ben c'est bon je vais vous faire la
conclusion sur votre incroyable talent
c'est quoi quelle est la conclusion
n'est pas de talent alors